[Music]
we're now reaching the end of the fourth
year of the worlds of speculative
fiction series for those of you who
don't know what that is
it's a talk series that I do here
locally partnering with the Brookfield
Public Library in the Greater Milwaukee
area and each month I take an author and
some set of their works that have a
coherent narrative universe and I come
in and give a little bit of background
on them talk about their world building
and then bring up some philosophical
themes over the years we've actually
gotten quite a few regulars who now very
much enjoy coming in and reading and
talking about these things sometimes
they actually know a little bit more
than I do and we're heading into year 5
so we've also got a tradition where I
get suggestions from all of you out
there in the ether on the internet
worldwide about who we ought to do next
so that's what this video is about and
you will be able to comment and make
some suggestions about who we ought to
do before you you launch into that I
want to tell you about who we did this
last year and who we've done in the
years past and then who we already have
coming up for 2020 so that you're not
just you know throwing spitballs out
there that have already gone stale you
might say all right so let's talk about
who we actually have lined up this
coming year
I have authors all the way from January
to September so that's nine and I'm
looking for three more slots to be
filled two of the ones that I have are
actually suggestions that came to me
from some of the regulars who attend the
series here locally and then three will
be ones that you get to suggest and then
ultimately vote on so what are they in
January we're doing Mary Shelley will be
looking at Frankenstein and the last man
I didn't get to do Shelley this this
last year so this is sort of a repeat in
February
we're doing Chyna Melville's boss-like
novels so that's perdido Street Station
the scar and iron Council in March will
be doing Stephen Donaldson's Chronicles
of Thomas covenant we're gonna look at
the first three books although I will
have by that time read all of the rest
of them as well that's quite an
investment in the series then we do
leave C's shins remembrance of Earth's
past series the three-body problem the
dark forest and deaths end in May we're
gonna do Veronica Roth's carved the mark
universe so the carve the mark book
fates divided and then some of the
stories from the end of the end and
other beginnings you may remember I did
a conversation with Veronica Roth here
in Milwaukee about her new book the end
in the other beginnings just about a
month and a half ago so I actually asked
her well should we do it on divergent
and that universe or should we do it on
carve the mark and she said that carve
the mark is probably narrative ly richer
and that was my intuition already so I
took that confirmation and ran with it
then in June we're gonna be talking
about somebody from the Milwaukee area
who went by the moniker cordwainer Smith
we'll be looking at his instrumentality
of humanity universe which includes a
lot of great short stories one of which
I read when I was very young and fell in
love with then then in July will be
since it's quite timely looking at
Margaret Atwood's Gilead novels so
that's the long ago written Handmaid's
Tale and then her recent book the
Testaments in August
great suggestion from one of the regular
attendees Larry Nivens Ringworld series
there's four books in that series all of
which are you know Ringworld this
Ringworld that and then in September
we're going to be looking at Marion
Zimmer Bradley as darkover series there
are a plethora of books in that series
so I picked storm Queen Hawke mistress 2
to conquer
and the heirs of Hammerfell because it's
right there in the middle of the you
know warring nations period of her her
narrative arc and universe and timeline
so there's three spots left over and
you're shortly going to get to make some
suggestions about those but first we
need to talk very briefly about all the
other authors that we've covered already
in this so I'm just gonna give you the
list here's the the authors that we've
already done so don't suggest these
because we've already done them Edgar
Allen Poe
GK Chesterton Lewis Carroll Tanith Lee
Gordon Dixon August Derleth Carl Edward
Wagner annals Huxley Bram Stoker and our
Scott backer the others that we
discussed in previous years would
include j.r.r tolkien a van Voigt CS
Lewis
Isaac Asimov Frank Herbert Roger Zelazny
Ursula Kayla Greene Michael Moorcock
philip k dick Mervyn Peake george RR
martin Philip Jose farmer Madeleine
L'Engle Douglas Adams Anne McCaffrey
Orson Scott Card Ian banks HP Lovecraft
William Gibson CL Moore
Octavia Butler horny Louie bore Hays
Fritz Leiber Robert Heinlein L Sprague
de camp Andre Norton Arthur Clarke
Robert Howard Gene Wolfe
CJ Terra and Jack Vance so that's those
are the ones that we're not going to
revisit and I'm going to put a list of
all of this within the video description
so just click on the you know read more
and you can see the whole list I am
however looking for suggestions what I'm
going to do is take the suggestions that
people leave as comments on this video
or on my social media in the post
specifically about this and I will take
the top say six or seven suggested
people so we're looking for those who
get to
Juston more than once by more than one
person right and don't you know don't
try to game creating a whole bunch of
fake personas to do this but we're gonna
take the top six or seven and then we'll
have a vote in say about a week or so
from now and then we'll have the lineup
for the final three thinkers for October
November December of the twenty twenty
year five of the worlds of speculative
fiction series so if there is an author
that isn't on that list of people that
we've already covered or people that
we're already going to cover and they
have a narrative universe not just one
book but but spread out across a couple
stories and coherent place doesn't even
have to be necessarily coherent
characters but a coherent place in which
it's set that's the sort of thing that
we're looking for speculative fiction so
you know we're not looking for a
realistic fiction we're looking for all
the different genres that fall under
that like fantasy horror sci-fi
alternate history utopian dystopian
literature you can look up what
speculative fiction is there's a lot of
discussion about that so I hope that
you'll get in on this and give me some
good suggestions and that you'll also
join in on the big float when we do that
[Music]